in chapter 620 out of one piece we're
told for the very first time about a
mysterious character called Joy boy and
over time he's turned into maybe the
single most important character in the
entire story next to Luffy so let's dig
into everything that we know about
joyboy for a fact as well as everything
that has been heavily hinted at starting
with why we know so little about this
character in the first place well you
see not having knowledge about Joy Boys
actually by Design because this person
lived around 800 years ago people who
know one piece know that these states
line up perfectly with a time period
called the void Century basically the
void century is an entire 100 Years of
History that's just gone the world
government the organization that
controls the entire one-piece World
eliminated every shred of information
and history connected to this specific
100 Year periods and so almost nothing
of it all remains no archaeological
ruins no books it all just vanished
without barely a trace except for one
big exception of course the pony glyphs
the SE ginormous indestructible blocks
are scattered across the world in a
mysterious language and pretty much the
only person in the entire world who is
able to read the pony glyphs is Nico
Robin the archaeologists of the straw
hat Pirates and so it's thanks to Robin
reading opponentlyph that we first heard
the name Joy boy in the series while the
crew was on fisherman Island Robin wrote
opponent live there and told us that it
described a promise between a man named
Joy boy and Poseidon from over 800 years
ago in case you don't know Poseidon is
this mermaid princess here and it's one
of the three ancient weapons whose power
is always reincarnated through the
Fishman royalty of the Fishman island
country whoever holds the power of
Poseidon can command the sea Kings
gigantic super powerful sea creatures
and right now the power of Poseidon
belongs to the mermaid princess Shira
Hoshi who Luffy saved during the
fisherman Island art always leave it to
Luffy to save a princess now the promise
between joyboy and Poseidon 800 years
ago had something to do with using the
sea Kings to lift up a massive Arc
called the Noah that sits at the bottom
of the ocean we don't really know but it
probably involves bringing the fishermen
to live among the surface along with the
other races of the one piece World
however for an unknown reason joyboy was
unable to hold up to his side of the
promise and so this Pony glyph actually
doesn't have any historical record on it
but is simply an apology to Fishman
Islands it was also around this same
time that joyboy was also partners with
zunisha a massive elephant and I mean
massive zonesha is confirmed to be 35
kilometers tall that means that Tunisia
is three times taller than The Sky
Islands are located above the sea level
so Nisha is so big in fact that a whole
island lives on top of it the minks a
race of animal human hybrids built their
entire civilization called Zoe right on
top of this giant elephant now the crazy
thing is that 800 years after the void
century zunisha is still alive and
kicking and has even communicated with
Luffy now zonesha doesn't literally talk
he communicates with other characters
through a mysterious power called the
voice of all things this exact same
power is also supposedly the way that
Roger was able to read the pony glyphs
without actually knowing how to read the
characters the thing is though that the
entire 800 years zunisha wasn't just
freely walking around the ocean he was
doing time that's right this elephant is
a criminal 800 years ago after
committing unstilled unknown crimes
Anisha was sentenced to walk a certain
path in the ocean continually for all
that time it was only once momonoski
gave him the order to do something else
that he finally could now for some
reason momonosuke the Shogun of wano has
the power to communicate with sanisha as
well as give orders to this gigantic
creature and so next to the fact that
zonesia was joyboy's loyal comrades
there are only two more things that are
actually confirmed pieces of information
about Joy boy number one is that joyboy
actually he was the one who left behind
the treasure that we now know as the one
piece while the series started off with
the pirate king Goldie Roger telling the
world that he left a treasure behind the
truth is a lot more complicated than
that because in reality at the end of
his journey Roger actually found some
kind of object of enormous importance
that was left behind by joyboy and on
that island Roger learned the truth of
the ancient history and the void century
and wished that he could have been alive
at the same time that joyboy was the
mysterious treasure that joyboy left
behind caused Roger to laugh like crazy
leading him to actually name this
Island's laugh tale and he also reveals
that for some reason he arrived at love
tale too early there goes Oda being
really mysterious about this entire
thing once again now we're not sure why
Raja was too early in arriving to love
tail but it probably has to do with
joyboy's Second Coming a prophecy that's
right Joy boy is coming back according
to this long held prophecy joyboy would
be reincarnated 800 years after the void
Century or 20 years after Roger rage
left tail now this prophecy is known in
parts thanks to a character named kozuki
Odin the former Shogun of the wano
country in fact the kozuki clan in
ancient times were the one who actually
wrote The Pony glyphs in the first place
now Odin sailed with Goldie Roger two
left tale and kept a logbook of their
travels and so when Raj and Odin learned
that they'd arrived too early and that
in 20 years Jabba would return to wano
it led Odin to make his goal opening
wano's borders to welcome joyboy back in
20 years later and the other thing that
we know for a fact about joyboy is that
he is none other than Monkey D Luffy
that's right our main character Luffy is
the second coming of the legendary hero
joyboy we know that because during his
fight with the emperor of the sea kaido
Luffy awakened a new power what Luffy
calls gear fifth is actually the
Awakening beginning of his devil fruit
and so after all these years in the
series we finally learned that Luffy's
devil fruit wasn't actually the rubber
fruit it was a super powerful devil
fruit called the sun god Nika devil
fruit now we still don't know much about
this deity called sangotnika but we can
guess that it's connected to Joy boy in
some way or form when Luffy transformed
his hair and clothes turned all white he
couldn't stop laughing he also gained
new powers that are seemingly only
limited by his imagination when Luffy
first appeared in this new form he was
also jumping across the battlefield
silhouetted by the moon and this mirrors
the very first time that we learned
about the sangod Nika from kaido
subordinate who is who because this guy
doesn't only have a really strange name
but he also tells us that while he was
in prison fellow inmates would tell
hopeful Tales of a liberator called the
sun Gods Nika and during this
explanation we also saw a figure with a
very similar silhouette to gear 5 Luffy
however when Luffy finally awakened this
forms Anisha the giant elephant said
something really fascinating he said
that he could hear the drums of
Liberation seemingly referring to
Luffy's heartbeat and he then announced
that Joy boy has returned and so clearly
Luffy joyboy and his son God [ __ ] are
all super closely related somehow now it
is kind of ironic that Luffy awakened
This Joy boy form while fighting kaido
because it seems like kaido was trying
to fight joyboy or possibly even become
joyboy himself through his entire life
it was hinted at a lot that he might
have chosen wano as his base of
operation because the prophecy hinted
that joyboy would appear in wano first
kaido's right-hand man king had told him
the legends of Joy boy long ago and
kaido seemed to become fascinated with
the prophecy and the legends of joyboy
freeing the world now kaido almost
defeated Luffy several times during
their massive battle after one defeat he
dropped Luffy into the sea stating so
you couldn't be Joy boy either clearly
kaido had seen others try and fail to
fill the role of joyboy before in fact
it might be the case that kaido himself
has failed at becoming Joy boy and even
after seeing kaido's flashbacks much of
his past is still mysterious in
retrospect it seems that he was obsessed
with being the strongest with creating
Warfare all across the world and with
being the strongest crew in the entire
ocean because he wanted to bring about
the return of Joy boy that's why he
followed this rule of survival of the
fittest after all part of the prophecy
of joyboy's return involved wano country
and its borders opening that's because
wano had closed its borders for
centuries and was basically isolated for
the rest of the world Joy boy someone
who spreads joy and happiness and the
sun god Nika who represent Freedom as
well as the drums of Liberation all of
these are connected in ways we can't
quite understand yet however since it's
still such a mystery that gives the fan
base a huge opportunity to make awesome
theories about how joyboy will play a
part in the story we gotta talk about a
few of those so before we get into those
if you don't want to miss any updates on
Joey Boy or one piece in general this
would be a great chance to subscribe to
the channel if you're enjoying this type
of content first off let's look at the
likely origin for Joy boy because Oda
might actually be drawing on history
when creating the idea of Joy boy in one
piece in the first place because the
idea for Joy boy very likely comes from
the Haitian God called well joy boy in
Voodoo believes joyboy is a god of Hope
and music it's likely that joyboy was
originally an African god that was then
brought to the Caribbean during the
slave trade now this God of happiness
and music is set to spread laughter and
joy with drumming and dancing which
would seem to connect to the ideas of
the drums of Liberation pretty perfect
this Haitian God also gave hope to
enslave people which would seem to
parallel what we've been told about the
sun god Nika in the story who is a
symbol of Hope for enslaved people in
the one piece world as well and to some
fans it seems like Joy boy and his huge
significance for the story have
basically come out of nowhere pretty
late in one piece however we all know
that Oda is the master of foreshadowing
and left us a lot of Clues before as
well we already mentioned that joyboy
was originally mentioned on opponent
glyph all the way back on Fishman
Islands but we've been getting plenty of
hints even before that as well like in
skypeia when Luffy was seen silhouetted
in front of a bonfire in a post that
looks just like the sun god Nika Oda has
even said that it was one of his top
three favorable panels of the entire
series that he's drawn and in the very
same Arc the shandorans are being told
to worship a Sun God as well the Giants
also worship a sun god and the sun
Pirates Who were formed by former slaves
were the mark of the sun on their body
an early hint about slaves praying to
the sun god [ __ ] for their freedom now
all of these oppressed people are
awaiting the dawn of the world a dawn
that can only come with the arrival of
the Sun so now let's talk about some of
the craziest theories about this
legendary character first off did
original Joy boy also wear a straw hat
you probably recall that in a froze
seller on the castle marijua the capital
of the world government the secret ruler
of the world government emu keeps a
massive straw hat in a frozen basement
but why did this secret object belong to
the first Joy boy Luffy's predecessor
and what then is the significance of the
smaller straw hat that was passed down
from Roger to shang's and then to Luffy
also what did joyboy really do that was
so significant we have so little
information about him that it's really
hard to say what he might have done
could he have been the ruler of the
ancient Kingdom that went up against the
world government the story has recently
revealed that the ancient kingdom was
technologically super Advanced so if
joyboy was its ruler could he have had
control over the ancient weapons as well
for sure holding that type of power
would be enough to make the world
government fearful as well as jealous I
mean it's even possible that joyboy did
create the ancient weapons in the first
well I mean if he's much like Luffy
probably not but speaking of that
advanced technique technology that Dr
vegapunk has revealed existed in the
ancient Kingdom what connections does
joyboy have to their mysterious power
source thus joyboy have something to do
with the recently revealed giant robot
that climbed the red line and tried to
attack marijua 200 years ago we have
only just learned about this powerful
new weapon of the ancient Kingdom but it
seems pretty convenient that at the same
time it attacked marijua fishermen were
also starting to fight for their rights
and does the mysterious technology of
joyboy's ancient Kingdom have something
to do with the people fighting for
Liberation or the coming of the Dom or
maybe joyboy was the world's first
pirate maybe he was a literal pirate
king not in a sense that Roger was
pirate king like having achieved all a
pirate could hope to achieve but joyboy
might have been the actual ruler of a
giant Pirate Kingdom so it would make a
lot of sense that the world government
which was 20 kingdoms back in the time
would try to erase his existence he was
their enemy in their War for Supremacy
over over the one piece World in
addition if he was a pirate it would
only make sense that the world
government would outlaw piracy even
against Pirates Who Don't steal or harm
any of the people and it's also very
possible that joyboy had the exact same
dream to Luffy wanting to spread freedom
and joy around the worlds maybe he
United all of the oppressed races of the
one piece World in one country because
if joyboy or the sangotnika are beacons
of hoped for all the enslaved and
suppressed people perhaps his dream was
to bring people together and prevent any
form of discrimination or hate for
instance the promise to the Fishman
might have been to use the argnoa to
bring them to the surface so that they
could live under the sun alongside the
humans a dream that all the fishermen
have had for centuries perhaps the Mings
wouldn't have had to hide on zanesha's
back anymore and could also step into
the light as well and maybe Luffy will
be able to keep the promise that the
original Joy boy broke also if the
original Joy boy had a giant straw hat
does that mean that Joy boy was a giant
and if he lived that long ago could he
have been an ancient Giant in fact there
are some pretty strong evidence that
joyboy could have been aorus the giant
zombie that the warlord gecko Mori
revived or one of his predecessors after
all if joyboy had a giant elephant and a
giant Straw Hat shouldn't he be a giant
himself as well and maybe it was more
than a coincidence that Luffy's Shadow
ended up being inside oars but if all of
that is not yet convincing to you then
you will probably need to check out this
video All About joyboy was an ancient
giant right here